so my name is Anna Sabri I'm a member of
parliament from Brock stay which is in
Nottingham sure I was a member of the
Conservative Party I left the Tory party
and I'm now a member of change UK
[Music]
so it's a very brave move to leave the
Conservative Party and move over to
change UK despite threats how is it the
experience been for you well it's for me
I've never regretted it and it felt a
very natural thing to do I mean I was I
was sorry to leave some of the activists
in brock's Toad helped you know me get
elected frankly and you know walk the
streets knocked on doors all weathers
for many years and so on and so forth
but for in terms of political terms and
I always I've always said and I feel
very strongly that it was the
Conservative Party that's left me and I
believe actually they've they've left
millions of other people because it's
moving to the right we could see this
now is ghastly leadership contest where
the winner is clearly going to be one
strain of a no deal hard brexit
representing the right wing of the
Conservative Party and the idea that the
party is a broad coalition was I think
absolutely gone and so I've never
doubted it was the right thing to do the
Tory parties they say on that move to
the right and I think we need to fix our
broken politics which I have no doubt
are absolutely broken in this country
and one of the things that that means is
that setting up a new party to capture
that centre moderate sensible but
radical and progressive ground is
absolutely critical
so could you speak more about what
change UK represents well it does
represent that centre ground so you've
got people who left the Conservative
Party one nation conservatives and then
you've got the old sensible moderate
labour people eight of them that left
their party we've come together in to
represent that Center ground that
sensible as I call it moderate way that
is the traditional way of actually doing
things in our country I think it
absolutely represents the majority of
people in our country and it's been
abandoned by the two main parties as
they've been gripped by the extremes of
British politics and other parties just
frankly haven't been able to step up and
meet the new challenge that's there and
how is your experience of the year
in elections been well I mean I think
it's been an amazing achievement that we
actually fielded 70 candidates I mean we
literally selected these people in a
matter of 10 days a week and we had 3700
people applying you look at the other
two main parties I mean they were
begging people to stand as candidates we
were almost say to people
police don't apply because we've got so
many people apply and say three thousand
seven hundred and then we've had rallies
throughout Great Britain which have been
really successful we've signed up me I
think it was in two weeks we signed up
another two thousand supporters so we've
now got 898 thousand supporters and
people are always absolutely behind this
project but I think we've done really
well just to feel that those candidates
taking part in these elections and do
you think the Lib Dems could have been
good allies for you or could be we if
had wanted to join the Lib Dems I would
have joined the Lib Dems in the first
political party ever joined with the
Liberals and I think you know I'm sure
they've done really well tonight and
good on them for that I think we just
have to be really honest about this you
know since the 2016 referendum the libs
really haven't captured if you like the
the remain vote especially the more
moderate centrist disaffected
conservative disaffected labour ground
they just haven't done that they did
well in the local elections and so they
should because that last set of
elections was held in 2015 when they did
spectacularly badly and of course they
had the bounce of those local elections
that meant that they were really gaining
speed as you'd expect into these EU
elections and I mean I have no doubt
there will be people who normally vote
Labour we know that there were members
of the Conservative Party people like
meThe Michael Heseltine Matthew Parris
from The Times for example who voted Lib
Dems now I would have loved them to have
put their faith and that led to us their
vote but they didn't we could have a
discussion as to why that was but I
think the most important thing is going
to be the overall remain vote but I
think we have to have some honest talk
about you
what's happened with the Lib Dems and
actually that then flows into my views
about what we should be doing with
politics because one of the things
that's blighted British politics for too
long is the inability of politicians to
be honest with the British people on any
particular subject
that's why we've found the rise of
populism that's why I think we getting
the drift off to the extremes there's
this great big gap there in the middle
and it needs filling with politicians
that will be honest and then also base
their policies and their bolete their
their vision for our country based on
evidence and not just on dog-whistle and
ideological cheap populism and so would
you see the success of the brexit party
in that need for honesty in politics or
is it that people are focused on a
brexit even if it's a No Deal practices
the brexit party is one of the most
dishonest bunch of politicians led by
Nigel Faraj who has spent a career
peddling myths preying on people's
prejudices fueling their fears and being
the entire the embodiment me of a
dishonest form of politics because
people have been sold this idea that we
can leave the European Union and
everything is going to be better which
is baloney because we know that however
you cut it brexit is going to harm our
economy and it will harm our country in
other ways as well but it will certainly
harm us economically and he's still
peddling this nonsense that if we leave
the European Union and now of course
he's changed his tack and he said I will
leave without a deal which is not what
people were promised which really will
be catastrophic for our country so I
think he's the embodiment in his party
of the dishonest part of the dishonesty
in British politics that's got us into
the dreadful state that we're
undoubtedly in and so how will you focus
on this
after European elections what will
change UK's focus well I I very much
hope now that we will absolutely get
ourselves together as a party as a
political force because I don't doubt
that there are millions of people out
and about in the real world who are
crying out for some party to represent
them and nobody at the moment represents
them and it's like I described it we're
not so much building a movement the
movements there it just needs a home
that it can rest in where it feels it's
got competent leadership and it's got
genuine honest politics and sound
policies based on evidence and while and
with the vision for the future and what
would be key successes for change UK big
key success I think it would be now to
get out and start to build that
manifesto with the the plan is to talk
to people that includes experts about
the sort of policies that we should have
on all the big topics that our country
faces both here in the United Kingdom in
Europe and obviously throughout the
world climate change being a really good
example of that and we need to come up
with the policies for the future because
our country is in a terrible place and
nobody is addressing those big issues
and it's like the rest of the world is
going on by like this River you know
it's flowing on behind me and we're not
even in a boat on it we're just like no
we're at the moment because we're
consumed by brexit which is completely
stifling everything that we should be
doing
and a lot of smaller parties have often
focused on how representative democracy
doesn't benefit them and they've focused
on the voting system that we have in
place is this something that changed UK
would look at absolutely look i-i've I
like the thing I like about
first-past-the-post and I know because
my friend Joe Swinson reprimanded me
about this that you can have a system of
proportional representation that still
delivers a person for a constituency
right you can do that I know that I also
though liked the idea I like I like what
they do in Wales and what they do in
Scotland but notably in Wales where you
have you have your constituency MP but
then you also have a more of a list
system so that you really make sure
you've got a properly representative set
of members of as it happens a Welsh
Assembly but and I can see that that
there must be a way that we do this
because the thing that I do know as an
MP is that your constituents like that
one person that they can go to and say
can you help me with this can you do
this for me yeah and you are directly
accountable to those people but also you
have a relationship with people so they
can come to you and you can do stuff for
them that need that then that needs
sorting out and it's it's a feature of
MPs work which actually not much talked
about it's got nothing to do with
politics but it's actually a substantial
part of what we actually do as members
of parliament
so it's really important I'm working
with other members of parliament now and
change UK are you seeing your own
opinions changing working with Labour
MPs no because that change had already
happened then I'd work with chakram you
know and Chris Leslie for nearly three
years now since the referendum I've got
to know chuck ordering the referendum
and then obviously afterwards you know
this it hacks me off a bit that people
say oh you all need to work together
while we've been chipping working
together for the last three years we've
not talked about it very much because a
lot of it has been very quiet we just
get on and do it and noticeably on
brexit the level of cross-party working
it has been it has been incredible and
if people knew the trust that there has
been so there's a whatsapp group that I
can think of which represents every
single plan every single political party
is in this group part of the brexit
party because it's a parliamentary
political parties it's never leaked
never leaked it's got Tory's labour
plied SNP Caroline Lucas to obviously
change labour we're all on it and we
speak very freely and we work together
in relation to brexit never linked and I
think that says everything so is it
actually an example of a really good
time or healthy time for politics so
it's a really [ __ ] time in politics
actually I think so doing hayek
supporting what's going on there's awful
beauty parade of all these dreadful hard
brexit ears you know do you just it's
just going to be a question of time
before it gets really dirty and nasty
and there'll be a lot of that dog
whistle type politics pandering to what
is now shrinking electorate of the
Conservative Party but it's and that the
membership has changed because it's been
infiltrated by a lot of old you kippers
and you've got people who will who's
going to be the most right-wing that's
how they you know that's how they're
going to win that election who can be
the hardest brexit here the most
irresponsible grexit here and who can
pander the most of the right-wing that's
taken over the Tory party I think that's
pretty a poor
and as I say in the meantime the real
problems that we should be looking at I
just gained she's not being done so
where's this green paper on social care
it's all well and good the government
and I congratulate for putting an extra
20 billion pounds into the NHS which it
needed of course but it's you know we
just keep throwing money at it which is
almost soaking up the that or dealing
with the mess but we're not actually
solving the many of the problems which
is one about how we make sure that we
look but people look after themselves
better and we prevent a lot of illnesses
and people getting sick in the first
place and of course the other huge piece
of work which we still haven't done is
hook up Social Care in the NHS and the
situation with too many older people who
are not getting the proper social care
and the health care that they need
means that there is this huge amount of
the NHS which just mopping it all up
whereas actually we should be investing
because you know we know what the
population is going to do that's the one
thing we can predict how long people are
going to live the sort of illnesses and
diseases they'll be living with and yet
we're not putting into place the sort of
stuff that we should be to be able to
mitigate a lot of that and actually stop
older people having to go to the
hospital in the first place because
they're being properly looked at in
either their care home or in their home
so there's masses of work that's got to
be done and nobody's doing it for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of Arts and
ideas her III TV
you